[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal mit Hanna
Zimmermann und Christian Siebers guten
Abend ihnen allen sie lesen alles über
den Fall und sie weinen dabei auch Jahre
danach das sagt einer der Ermittler über
die Angehörigen der Opfer von Flug mh17
298 Menschen die meisten von ihnen
niederländische Urlauber voller
Vorfreude auf ein paar entspannte Tage
werden je aus dem Leben gerissen als
ihre Maschine über der Ostukraine
abstürzt weil sie eine Rakete getroffen
hat die Hinterbliebenen müssen danach
acht Jahre und vier Monate warten in der
Hoffnung auf einen Tag der Gerechtigkeit
heute ist der gekommen ein Strafgericht
in Amsterdams spricht drei Männer
schuldig die sich aktuell wohl in
Russland aufhalten lebenslänglich wegen
Mordes in 298 Fällen es stellt auch die
Verantwortung des russischen Staates
Fest der ja weiterhin Krieg führt in der
Ukraine und es beendet ein beispielloses
abstreiten Lügen Fälschen von Fährten
staatliches Streuen von Fake News dass
nicht nur bei den Angehörigen zusätzlich
Wunden Aufriss Gunnar Krüger
Minuten nach dem Urteil steht Selene
Fredericks mitten im Medienrummel
wir bekommen unsere Kinder nie zurück
aber das ist ein Stück Gerechtigkeit
[Musik]
im Juli 2014
ihr Sohn 23 Jahre alt seine Freundin
Daisy 20
hinschaue werde ich traurig aber ich
möchte sie immer bei mir haben
selene und ihr Mann sagen der Schmerz
geht nie weg auch nicht acht Jahre
danach
17 Juli 2014 Emma 17 hebt ab Ziel ist
Koala Lumpur doch nach gut drei Stunden
fallen Trümmer ins Getreide weil du
jetzt im Osten der Ukraine schon damals
herrscht Krieg doch nicht alle wollen
sehen dahinter steht Russland
mh17 zwang die Niederländer zu frühen
Einsichten das Mahnmal ist ein Blick in
den Himmel
Pete Plug ist der Sprecher der
Angehörigen die
Opfer von Flug mh17 waren die ersten
nicht Ukraine
darauf gibt das Gericht nun sein Siegel
die Separatisten im Donbass standen
unter Moskaus Kommando alle Fakten
sprechen dafür
dass man von Mitte Mai 2014 ein von
einer Situation sprechen kann in der die
Russische Föderation die volle Kontrolle
über die du nietzger Volksrepublik hatte
damit stärkt das Gericht die Argumente
der Ukraine vor dem Europäischen
Gerichtshof für Menschenrechte und dem
Internationalen Gerichtshof wo sie auch
versucht Urteile gegen Russland zu
bewirken
Gerichte als Schlachtfeld vor denen mit
dem Urteil auch Bilder aus dem Netz als
Beweise zählen ein Luftabwehrsystem
fährt bis unter die Flugroute und mit
einer Rakete weniger zurück offene
Quellen dazu abgehörte Telefone
Ermittler aus fünf Ländern hielten vier
Männer für schuldig das Gericht folgte
ihnen im Fall von zwei Russen und einem
Ukraine
in Anbetracht der Schwere der bewiesenen
Taten und der Höhe der Strafe ordnet das
Gericht ihre Festnahme an
russland will das Urteil prüfen eine
Inhaftierung unwahrscheinlich eine
Auslieferung ausgeschlossen das weiß
auch Pete blue na bestanden sind die
Angehörigen wollten die Wahrheit wissen
wir wollten das Recht gesprochen wird
das sei nun geschehen auch wenn auf
Schuld vorerst keine Strafe folgt
den staatlichen Lügen aus Moskau den
Rechtsstaat entgegensetzen das ist das
war die Idee sarattacke ist bei uns
unsere Rechtsexpertin guten Abend Sarah
wir haben es gerade gehört die
Verurteilten waren gar nicht da russland
will und wird sie auch nicht ausliefern
ein Verfahren also mit Lehrer
Anklagebank welchen Sinn macht das
juristisch klar ist das Verfahren und
auch das Urteil hat erstmal vor allem
symbolische Bedeutung und Wirkkraft aber
genau die ist nicht zu unterschätzen
ganz grundsätzlich in jedem Strafprozess
geht es nicht nur darum dass am Ende
Schuldige ins Gefängnis geschickt werden
und es geht darum Wahrheit zu finden die
Hintergründe einer Tat aufzuklären es
geht darum Zeugen zu hören Beweise zu
sichten Beweise auch zu bewerten und
genau das hat die niederländische Justiz
in den zwei Jahren sehr detailliert sehr
mühevoll gemacht und ist am Ende zu
einem rechtsstaatlichen Ergebnis
gekommen dreimal lebenslange Haft ein
Freispruch genau das ist ein wichtiges
rechtsstaatliches Signal dann gucken wir
mal wie die Justiz zu diesem Ergebnis
gekommen ist da haben statistische
investigativgruppen entscheidend zu
beigetragen berlingcad zum Beispiel
heißt das dass die Justiz selbst mit
ihren Mitteln da an Grenzen gestoßen ist
ja und nein nein weil es immer wieder so
ist dass durch journalistische
Recherchen und journalistische
Veröffentlichung Staatsanwaltschaften
Anfangsverdacht haben am Ende vielleicht
auch eine Verurteilung stehen kann aber
auch ja weil natürlich gerade bei
internationalen Fällen ist für Mittler
enorm schwierig ist diese aufzuklären
und da haben diese Beweise die
Journalisten gefunden und
zusammengetragen haben enorm geholfen
jetzt haben wir auch gesehen in diesem
Prozess dass digitale Beweise wenn man
so will also zum Beispiel
Satellitenfotos eine entscheidende Rolle
gespielt haben ist es das was auch über
diesen Tag hinaus bleiben wird auch mit
Blick auf andere Kriegsverbrechen die
ganz aktuelle in der Ukraine passieren
ganz klar ja und nicht nur mit Blick auf
die Ukraine grundsätzlich ist es so dass
digitale Beweise aus offenen Quellen
wichtig sind schon jetzt und immer
wichtiger werden wir sprechen darüber
Handy Fotos in sozialen Netzwerken über
Überwachung und Videoaufnahmen über
tracking-apps all das sind digitale
Beweise die aktuell auch schon am
Internationalen Strafgerichtshof für
Ermittlungsverfahren zur
Ermittlungsverfahren geführt haben klar
es aber auch all diese Beweise die
zusammengetragen werden müssen immer
überprüft werden ob sie wirklich echt
sind und nur wenn sie echt sind und
gerichtsfest sind können sie auch
verwertet werden am Ende auch zu einer
Verurteilung führen also ein wichtiger
Tag für das internationale Recht heute
auf jeden Fall Sarah herzlichen Dank
dass du bei uns warst
als die schreckliche Nachricht von MH 17
um die Welt ging hatte Russland noch
behauptet mit den Pro russischen
Separatisten in der Ostukraine nun
wirklich nichts zu tun zu haben
mittlerweile führt der Kreml dort ein
offenen Krieg und hat ganze Gebiete in
der Ostukraine zu russischem Territorium
erklärt gegen jedes Völkerrecht und
damit seine Lügen von damals selbst
entlarvt die Situation in der Ukraine
heute und die Reaktionen dort auf das
Urteil schildert
in Erinnerung an die Toten 298 Menschen
unschuldige Opfer eines Bürgerkrieges so
steht es auf der kleinen Gedenktafel bei
rabore das freie Feld auf dem 2014 große
Teile des abgeschossenen Flugzeuges
stürzten sonst erinnert heute nicht mehr
viel an damals geblieben aber die
Erinnerung auch bei den Menschen
ich vermutete damals eine ukrainische
Militärmaschine sei abgeschossen worden
aber dann sah ich all die Menschen hier
liegen überall und dachte sofort dass
das kein solches Transportflugzeug
gewesen sein kann
mehr als acht Jahre später rabauve liegt
im russisch besetzten Teil der Ukraine
umso wichtiger für die Ukraine das
heutige Urteil
über Twitter begrüßt Präsident
selenskias und auch in Richtung Russland
schreibt er
drahtzia zur Rechenschaft zu ziehen ist
ebenfalls von entscheidender Bedeutung
da das Gefühl der Straflosigkeit zu
neuen Verbrechen führt wir müssen diese
Illusion zerstören die Bestrafung aller
russischen Gräueltaten damals wie heute
wird unvermeidlich sein
die Erinnerung bleibt lebendig dabei hat
das Land aktuell genug Sorgen Kiew es
ist frostig geworden erster Schnee liegt
in der ukrainischen Hauptstadt zuletzt
gab es hier immer wieder Stromausfälle
als Folge russischer Angriffe auch heute
war Kiew wieder Ziel von Raketen nach
Aussagen des Militärs konnten allerdings
Marschflugkörper und Drohnen
abgeschossen werden nicht so in japo im
Osten der Ukraine hier schlugen sie ein
offiziell gab es nur verletzte
Einschläge werden heute auch aus anderen
Städten gemeldet auch aus Odessa und
williamsk
neben Wohnhäusern waren wieder vor allem
Stromleitungen Kraft und Gaswerke
zielrussischer Angriffe wie die ganze
Woche schon die Infrastruktur stark
beschädigt viele Städte Millionen
Menschen waren bereits in den
vergangenen Tagen ohne lichtstromheizung
vielerorts konnte die Stromversorgung
weitestgehend wiederhergestellt werden
die Situation aber bleibt kritisch
Russland kämpft mit seinen Raketen gegen
Strom und Wärme für die Menschen sprengt
Kraftwerke und andere Energieanlagen in
die Luft das ist jetzt der Alltag in der
Ukraine wegen des russischen Terrors
auch weil die Angriffe fortgesetzt
werden die heute die russische Regierung
noch einmal betont
kremlsprecher pestov sagt per Telefon
gegenüber Journalisten die russischen
Streitkräfte zielten weiter auf
Infrastruktur die direkt oder indirekt
mit den ukrainischen Streitkräften in
Verbindung stehen
zumindest in einem Punkt hat sich
Russland heute gesprächsbereit gezeigt
unter Vermittlung der Türkei und der UN
haben sich der Kreml und die Ukraine auf
eine Verlängerung der getreideausfuhren
über das Schwarze Meer geeinigt bis März
wenigstens das
unser nächstes Thema der
UNO-Generalsekretär ein Mann der
ausgewogenen Worte ist zunehmend
verzweifelt die Welt brennt und ertrinkt
vor unseren Augen sagt er und es muss
gehandelt werden man kann die
Verzweiflung des Diplomaten förmlich
spüren und er hat jeden Grund
verzweifelt zu sein seine Klimakonferenz
in Ägypten sollen nach fast zwei Wochen
morgen eigentlich planmäßig zu Ende sein
aber von konkretem Fortschritt ist wenig
zu berichten nun gehen UNO
Klimakonferenzen beinahe schon
traditionell in die Verlängerung und
Zeitdruck hilft ja häufig auch dabei
endlich zu Potter zu kommen aber dieses
Mal scheint die Lage deutlich
verzwickter als sonst berichtet wie nie
Hecher aus Sharm el Sheikh
liefe diese Klimakonferenz wie andere
hätte hier niemand Zeit für eine
ausgedehnte Mittagspause normalerweise
würden am Tag vor dem großen Finale alle
Beobachter ihre Köpfe über einem Entwurf
fürs Abschlusspapier rauchen lassen aber
das Papier gibt es nicht was es hier
gibt ist Frust
die Welt brennt und ertrinkt vor unseren
Augen ich fordere alle Parteien auf zu
zeigen dass sie das Sehen und begreifen
und ein Signal senden dass die gehört
werden die an der Frontlinie dieser
Klimakrise stehen
sie stehen an diesem Abgrund weil ihre
Heimat durch Überflutungen Stürme Dürre
schon Schaden genommen hat die
Entwicklungsländer fordern Geld von den
Industriestaaten von denen die durch
CO2-Emissionen den Klimawandel befeuern
die fühlen sich ohnehin allein gelassen
woher bin wir warten jetzt schon sieben
Jahre vergeblich das die
Industriestaaten ihr versprechen uns mit
100 Milliarden Dollar jährlich zu
unterstützen einhalten das muss doch
möglich sein
die deutsche Außenministerin war dafür
dass das Thema klimaentschädigungen hier
erstmals verhandelt wird sie will aber
so wie die meisten anderen
Industrienationen keine blanco-checks
ausstellen damit das Geld nicht irgendwo
versickert oder an die Falschen gerät
großen Emittenten
können jetzt zeigen dass sie zu mehr
Ambition und mehr Solidarität bereit
sind
Annalena baerbock sagt es nicht sie
meint China sie will verhindern dass
China als einer der größten CO2
Emittenten sich hier aus allen
Verpflichtungen stiehlt je nach Belieben
China spielt hier eine recht
interessante Rolle denn auf der einen
Seite unterstützen sie die gesamte
Gruppe der Entwicklungsländer dass ein
Fort zu Bewältigung von Klimaschäden
eingerichtet werden soll auf der anderen
Seite wollen sie aber selbst als großer
Verursacher dieser Klimakrise kein Geld
einbezahlen das Ende der Geschichte
dieser Klimakonferenz ist noch nicht
geschrieben bislang gibt's wenig Licht
viel Schatten
wenn weiter berichten es tut sich was im
US-Parlament was die Mehrheiten angeht
und das Spitzenpersonal Hanna ja
das Ergebnis hatte sich bereits
abgezeichnet die Republikaner haben laut
US-Medien die Mehrheit im
Repräsentantenhaus knapp zurückerobert
damit können Sie künftig die Arbeit der
Regierung von Präsident beiden
erschweren indem sie zum Beispiel
Gesetzesvorhaben blockieren die
bisherige Vorsitzende des
US-Repräsentantenhauses nennt sie pelosy
erklärte heute dass sie auch für den
Fraktionsvorsitz der Demokraten in der
Parlamentskammer nicht mehr kandidieren
wolle im Senat konnten die Demokraten
bei den Kongresswahlen vergangene Woche
ihre Mehrheit verteidigen
in Berlin hat Bundesfamilienministerin
Pauls eine neue Kampagne gegen sexuelle
Gewalt an Kindern und Jugendlichen
vorgestellt sie zielt darauf ab lokale
Netzwerke und kommunale Initiativen zu
stärken und mehr Bewusstsein für das
Problem zu schaffen gemeinsam mit der
Missbrauchsbeauftragten des bundesklaus
hob sie noch einmal hervor das Kinder
vor allem im familiären Umfeld der
Gefahr sexueller Gewalt ausgesetzt sind
Großbritanniens neue Regierung hat
umfangreiche Steuererhöhungen und
Ausgabenkürzungen angekündigt und so
dass riesige Haushaltsloch von fast 63
Milliarden Euro zu stopfen
Finanzminister Hand kündigte in seinem
Haushaltsentwurf unter anderem an dass
die übergewinnsteuer für Öl-
müssen mehr Steuern zahlen das ist eine
echte Kehrtwende die Vorgängerregierung
hatte noch auf Schulden finanzierte
Steuersenkungen gesetzt und damit für
heftige Turbulenzen an den Märkten
gesorgt
die Militär runter in Myanmar lässt im
Zuge einer massenamnestie fast 5.800
Gefangene frei darunter auch mehrere
Ausländer wie die ehemalige britische
Botschafterin Vicky Baumann und der
australische Ökonom chansonell der
früher Berater der entmachteten
Regierungschefin zu Chiva
US-Außenminister blinken äußerte sich
zurückhaltend und erklärte dass er nicht
sagen könne ob die Amnestie Ausdruck für
einen echten Kurswechsel des Regimes sei
fast sechs Jahre Haft das ist mehr als
ein Urteil heute das soll ein Zeichen
sein vom Landgericht in Frankfurt am
Main Sprache können genauso verletzen
wie ein körperlicher Angriff und mit
Sprache hatte der Angeklagte angegriffen
Todesdrohungen verschickt
Gewaltfantasien rassistische
Beleidigungen an Rechtsanwälte
PolitikerInnen Journalistin das Urteil
heute sieht ihnen als Einzeltäter
mehrere Adressaten der Drohungen sehen
das anders und haben noch Fragen Peter
Wagner
Artikel 1 Grundgesetz die Würde des
Menschen ist unantastbar prangt als
Städte Mahnung von der Fassade des
Frankfurter Landgerichts die Würde der
vielen Opfer der NSU 2.0 Drohbrief Serie
aber wurde massiv angetastet sie wurden
bedroht beleidigt traumatisiert und das
Gericht ist sicher dass der 54-Jährige
Alexander Emmaus Berlin all diese
unsäglichen drohscheiben wie aus einem
Guss verfasst und verschickt hat der
Arbeitslose IT-Techniker hat für
drohscheiben Informationen genutzt die
zuvor auf hessischen und Berliner
Polizei Computern abgerufen wurden dazu
soll der Täter unter gefälschten
Telefonnummern angerufen sich etwa als
Staatsanwalt ausgegeben und Polizisten
gewissermaßen übertötet haben
sehr viele zentrale Fragen sind offen
ich meine es ist nicht erklärt worden
wie der Täter an gesperrte Adressen
kommen kann also das ist auch
telefonisch durch telefonische Anfragen
ausgeschlossen und diese zentrale Frage
ist nicht geklärt und er kann das auch
nicht alleine gemacht haben naja das hat
ja die Richterin würde ich sagen ja
selber auch kritische Stück weit in
ihrem Urteil angesprochen dass sie
gesagt hat es ist uns nicht gelungen das
aufzuklären also die Datenabfragen
aufzuklären die Hintergründe aufzuklären
das hat sie ja selber deutlich gemacht
und damit sagt sie auch selber das ist
da offene Fragen gibt diese Fragen sind
Gegenstand anderer noch laufender
Verfahren gegen hessische Polizisten
Demonstranten vor Gericht haben Zweifel
vermuten ein rechtes Netzwerk bei der
hessischen Polizei nein sagt die Polizei
Gewerkschaft die schwarzen Schafe sein
längst aus dem Dienst entfernt aber ich
bleibe dabei
99,8% meiner Kolleginnen und Kollegen
haben sich nichts zu Schulden kommen
lassen und das ist ein klares Statement
als Konsequenz aus den Datenabfragen in
hessischen Polizeirevieren im
Zusammenhang mit den drohscheiben oder
massiv in die IT-Sicherheit investiert
Polizistinnen und Polizisten können sich
nur noch mit ihren eigenen biometrischen
Daten in die Systeme einloggen und diese
nutzen Missbrauch soll so unmöglich
werden man weiß jederzeit wer nach
welchem Begriffen wo und wann gesucht
hat die Zeiten in denen jeder auf dem
Revier die Passwörter der Kollegen
nutzen konnte sind vorbei
das Landgericht Frankfurt hat heute ein
wegweisendes Urteil gegen Hass und Hetze
gesprochen voller Empathie für die Opfer
ein Gefühl das Alexander m völlig fremd
zu sein scheint er bestreitet nach wie
vor die Täterschaft
so und jetzt von der Börse Nachrichten
die angesichts der Gesamtlage einen doch
einigermaßen verwundert die Augen reiben
lassen Hannah trotz der Unsicherheiten
der hohen Inflation und der Energiekrise
Brummen die Geschäfte bei den
Dax-Konzernen laut einer Auswertung
haben sie ein rekord-quartal hingelegt
und es könnte sogar ein Rekord ja werden
Valerie Haller in Frankfurt das sind
Nachrichten die angesichts der
Widrigkeiten durchaus überraschen wie
ist das zu erklären ja bislang gelingt
es den meisten Dax-Konzernen die
gestiegenen Kosten also für
personalmaterial und Energie und
ähnliches auf die Kunden abzuwälzen auch
scheint die Nachfrage noch nicht
eingebrochen zu sein zumindest nicht bis
zum dritten Quartal außerdem haben viele
Unternehmen volle Auftragsbücher und das
ist ein ziemlich guter Puffer wenn es
dann nicht mehr so gut läuft laut einer
Studie sind die operativen Gewinne der
40 Dax-Konzerne im dritten Quartal um
28% gestiegen das könnte ein re werden
stärkste Unternehmen waren Mercedes
Volkswagen und Siemens Siemens
präsentierte heute als Letzter
DAX-Konzern seine Zahlen ein
Milliardengewinn die Börse dankt's mit
einem Kursfeuerwerk gute Geschäfte
machen deutsche Unternehmen aktuell vor
allem in den USA dabei hilft das der
Euro gegenüber dem Dollar kräftig an
Wert verloren hat was made in Germany
günstiger macht für den amerikanischen
Markt fraglich ist wie sich die Lage für
viele Unternehmen weiterentwickelt die
Herausforderungen sind riesig besonders
für Unternehmen die viel Strom und Gas
für Ihr Geschäft brauchen auf die
Polster wird es ankommen die sich die
Unternehmen zugelegt haben bei einigen
sind sie dick und ob sie reichen um
einen harten Einbruch abzuwenden wird
sich zeigen danke Valerie für deine
Einschätzung
es gibt neue Hoffnung für die
Beschäftigten der insolventen MV Werften
in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern der
Disney-Konzern hat die fast
fertiggestellte global Dream gekauft die
zu den größten Kreuzfahrtschiffen der
Welt gehört zuvor war monatelang
vergeblich ein Käufer gesucht worden das
Kreuzfahrtschiff soll in Wismar
fertiggestellt werden allerdings ist
noch unklar wie viele Beschäftigte
hierfür übernommen werden derzeit
befinden sich rund 900 Mitarbeiterinnen
und Mitarbeiter in der
Transfergesellschaft
seit dem Nachmittag ist es zu
bundesweiten Störungen im Mobilfunknetz
von o2 gekommen auch Notrufe waren davon
mancherorts betroffen Grund für die
Einschränkungen sei eine technische
Störung erklärte das Unternehmen diese
sei teilweise behoben worden
in Niedersachsen sind am frühen Morgen
zwei Güterzüge zusammengestoßen ein
Lokführer wurde dabei leicht verletzt
und es entstand erheblicher Schaden auch
an der Oberleitung damit bleibt die
wichtige Bahnstrecke zwischen Hannover
und Berlin erstmal gesperrt und das
Polizei vermutlich noch für einige Tage
zahlreiche IC und ICE Verbindungen
vielen aus und es wird ein paar Tage
noch zu Verspätungen kommen
drei Tage vor Beginn der
Fußballweltmeisterschaft ist die
deutsche Nationalmannschaft im WM
Gastgeberland Katar angekommen ihr
Teamquartier bezog die Nationalelf in
großer Abgeschiedenheit im Norden des
Landes in der Nähe wird auch das
Training stattfinden die Mannschaft
wolle dort einen Spirit entwickeln der
sie durch das Turnier trage solange wie
möglich sagte dfb-direktor Oliver
Bierhoff
so die nächsten knapp drei Minuten heute
journal gehören einem einzigen Lied an
dem sich das Genie seines Schöpfers
zeigt und dessen Biografie er hat lange
dran gearbeitet das Ergebnis ist ein
Ohrwurm mit Eigenleben schwer zu greifen
aber irgendwie immer passend kein Wunder
dass es mittlerweile über 300
Cover-Versionen gibt und jetzt einen
ganzen Kinofilm über diesen einen Song
auf seiner letzten Tunnel so beginnt der
Dokumentarfilm hallelujah
zwei Stunden über einen einzigen Song
das klingt gewagt aber es ist nicht
irgendein Song
dieser unglaubliche Verlauf er ist das
qualvolle Song schreiben dann die
Ablehnung schließlich der unerwartete
Erfolg die Geschichte dieses Songs hat
uns einfach gepackt
sieben Jahre trugen die Filmemacher
unzählige archivausschnitte zusammen auf
der Suche nach dem was Halleluja
ausmacht
Leonard Cohen stammt aus einer
religiösen Familie sein Großvater ein
bedeutender
der Song beginnt mit dem biblischen
König David der auf seiner Harfe nach
dem einen Akkord sucht der Gott gefällt
doch dann kommt die zweite Strophe
David beobachtet die nackte badseeba
beim Bart und er will sie mehr als alles
andere auch das ist seine Geschichte
Cohen der Verführer Halleluja soll für
ihn das spirituelle und das Körperliche
in Einklang bringen ihn heilen eine kaum
lösbare Aufgabe
[Musik]
sieben Jahre schrieb unzählige Strophen
1984 ist das Album mit Halleluja endlich
fertig doch
[Musik]
das Ende eine Anfang eine Reihe von
Musikern coverte den Song
[Musik]
braucht es allerdings einen besonderen
Helden
[Musik]
der Soundtrack von Schreck machte
Halleluja berühmt
war das schon Jahre nicht mehr
aufgetreten hatte sich in einen
buddhistisches Kloster zurückgezogen
mit über 70 stand er wieder auf der
Bühne am Ende seines Lebens mit sich im
Reinen
auch wenn der Film sich manchmal in
Details verliert Halleluja ist die
sehenswerte Geschichte über ein
besonderes Lied und über den Mann der es
geschrieben hat
und diese Stimme Beitrag von Ralf
Rettich der filmhalle Luja journey a
song startet heute in den deutschen
Kinos und dieses heute-journal geht zu
Ende nicht ohne den Hinweis auf das was
spannendes nach uns kommt ein grüner
Wirtschaftsminister und der
Vorstandschef der blauen Bank das Thema
Energie Geld Jobs keine Strategie in der
mega-krise Fragezeichen und Maybrit
Illner natürlich
und gegen 0:30 Uhr ist mache ich gleich
mal weiter
das darf ich heute mal machen und zwar
mit Christopher Wehrmann ganz wichtig
dass du das auch noch untergebracht
haben Ihnen einen angenehm haben tschüss
[Musik]
guten Abend heute brachte das Tief
Regina im Südwesten noch recht milde
Temperaturen mit aber das wird sich
ändern das liegt an dieser
nord-ostströmung sehr kalt wird es also
von Nordosten und über der Ostsee gibt
es auch einige Schneeschauer Schnee
fällt aber auch bei uns in der zweiten
Nachthälfte da mischen sich immer mehr
Schneeflocken hier zwischen
Nordfriesland und der Uckermark unter
den Regen und auch am alten Rand kann es
etwas schneiden so wird es also glatt
auf Straßen und Gehwegen und das ganz
besonders hier im Nordosten denn da
sinken die Temperaturen auf plus zwei
bis minus drei Grad milder bleibt es an
mein Mosel rein und lecker mit acht bis
sechs Grad und morgen gibt es eine
gegenläufige Entwicklung zum einen
kommen von Südwesten noch weitere
Regenschauer heran zum anderen sieht
dieses schneeregenband aus dem Nordosten
weiter in Richtung Südwesten und da
reicht bis zum Abend etwa Bremen und
Chemnitz so bleibt es also gefährlich
glatt auf den Straßen im Nordosten
lockern die Wolken auf da scheint die
Sonne zum Teil Strahlen direkt an der
Ostseeküste vieles einige Schauer geben
die Temperaturen liegen Morgen rund um
Berlin nur um ein Grad am Rhein werden
es dagegen bis zu 12 Grad ja und ähnlich
wechselhaft geht es auch am Samstag
weiter mit weiteren schneeregenfällen
der Sonntag wird schon freundlicher und
der Montag etwas milder und wie sie
jetzt hier am Temperaturen wettertrend
für Magdeburg sehen können ist das dann
auch die Tendenz bis zum ersten Advent
die Temperaturen tagsüber gehen Richtung
10 Grad und nachts kommen die Werte aus
dem Frost raus bis bald